it is a decision a lot of people have
been waiting to hear masks are no longer
mandated in nevada now there still are
some exceptions but most indoor public
places no longer require wearing a mask
including college campuses and ccsd
classrooms sasha loftus spoke with
parents tonight about the big change
[Applause]
yes brian and denise this has been
especially tough these
this pandemic and these restrictions on
our kids now we went to a local
basketball game tonight a high school
basketball game and kids didn't have to
wear face masks for the first time in a
really long time parents we spoke with
say it's a new world for everyone
nevada will rescind our mask mandate
effective immediately it's a sentence so
many have been waiting to hear after
nearly two years masks are no longer
mandated in nevada we were elated it's
big news for everyone and parents we
spoke with call it especially crucial
for their kids moving forward
following the governor's announcement
ccsd issued a statement saying masks
would no longer be required after the
end of thursday's school day
teacher and parent derrick thomas says
face coverings have been a real
challenge both in and out of the
classroom and he thinks friday will mark
a new beginning i got to make sure i
understand who some of my students are
because i don't see their eyes usually
so i get to actually meet them now but
some like christina brooks tell us it's
too soon especially for those who are
immunocompromised she wants more options
for her daughter to feel safe the
governor did not think this through we
should have had some warning regardless
of whether you're for or against the
change many are already embracing it
[Applause]
ready to experience life in a post
pandemic world i understand why we had
to do it but hopefully we want to do it
anymore
now students parents teachers staff
anyone will not have to wear masks on
school campuses but they are still
required on school buses now of course
students anyone really has the option on
any campus or anywhere really to still
wear a mask if they prefer it reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now